everyone welcome back for part two our
discussion on the sort of magical
classical guitar technique called
tremolo to really benefit from today's
episode I'd strongly suggest that you
spend a good deal of time working on the
exercises I taught you in part one so
watch that if you haven't already and
for the rest of you here is tremolo part
two
[Music]
today I'd like to help you bring your
tremolo to the next level to do that I'm
going to show you two more exercises
that's going to work out any remaining
kinks in your tremolo technique and then
we'll finish the episode by talking
about how to add musicality to your
tremolo
[Music]
very often I'll hear guitarists who have
certainly put in their fair share of
hours working on tremolo however when
they try to play fast they end up
producing a sort of lopsided sound that
has an almost galloping effect rather
than what we want which is a sort of
ethereal evenness it's almost as if
there's an instrument in the other room
sustaining that's the goal so to fix
this unevenness we can practice swinging
the rhythm back and forth so for example
we can start by going P am I
so it's long-short long-short long-short
long-short we can also practice short
long short long short long like this
you
etc this exercise is great for exposing
the micro imperfections that can occur
between our rapid finger movements
most guitarists have had the experience
that once they get good at tremolo on
the first string they're required to
play it on the second string and that
can be difficult to get rid of this
let's learn about the concepts of
flexion and extension so flexion is this
motion here just the fingers closing
toward the palm and in fact we can
remember what Fernandez or says about
plucking plucking is simply closing the
hand one finger at a time so that means
that we go from our point of rest which
is this natural curled shape of the
finger and we close the hand one finger
at a time and after that finger plucks
it can then just let go and it naturally
springs back to its point of rest which
is kind of cool actually you can hold
your finger down to it palm let go and
it springs back to where it was so every
pluck starts by touching the string
plucking letting the finger release so
it springs back to its point of rest
hovering over the string ready to bluff
again
[Music]
now the common mistake with tremolo is
people accidentally do this this is
called extension and we don't want to
extend the fingers past their point of
rest we want to let the fingers flex
towards the palm release return to the
point of rest but some good hearts
accidentally extend the finger past the
string there by hitting the first string
makes for a messy tremolo to practice
playing on the inside strings let's just
do PA mi on every single string like
this
all the way down back up
now the rest of this video is going to
be about musicality which involves some
serious multitasking so if you are
struggling at all with the technical
portion of tremolo don't be afraid to
spend a few weeks maybe practicing 10
minutes a day with these exercises and
come back this video will be here when
you're ready
[Music]
most tremolo pieces are in two parts
there's an accompaniment and a melody
the melody is usually the singable part
and the accompaniment just provides
harmonic supports in required us for
example the melody is the upper part the
tremolo a bit and then the thumb
provides the accompaniment by
arpeggiating chords
and just like as if we were in an
orchestra when there are several
different musicians we have to control
the balance between the different parts
and since we have two different voices
here this is no different so we as
guitarists have to be able to control
the volume disparity between those two
parts and the way you can do that is by
controlling the height of the wrist if
we bring the wrist higher it's going to
bring the bass line the accompaniment
out if you bring it lower it'll make it
softer and the melody will appear to be
louder so here we have the accompaniment
starting with a low wrist and I'm going
to raise the rest height
cutlery
it's more resonant to and if I bring the
wrist back down
they got quieter I'm not changing the
force of the thumb I'm just changing the
height of the wrist and the reason this
works is because as I raise my wrist
higher I'm putting more arm weight into
the string which makes the note sound
louder and more resonant so now when I'm
playing the piece if I want to bring out
the melody I can lower the wrist which
turns the volume down there and that'll
make the melody appear as louder if I
just take the first chord this is the
first chord of the major section I can
gradually lower the rest and now you
hear that melody as being much louder
raise the wrist
[Music]
now although in most music the melody is
louder than the accompaniment when
something interesting happens in the
accompaniment you can bring out that
sound like at the end of a queer dose
you get this interesting little bass
line which is nice and melodic and at
the same moment the melody is just
droning on a c-sharp so that's a good
moment to bring out the accompaniment by
raising the wrist height so here's that
whole phrase it starts with the melody
louder
[Music]
dynamics are an essential part of any
musical performance and is no different
with tremolo
[Music]
so to learn how to crescendo and
decrescendo while performing tremolo
let's just take the opening chord of
Ricardo's and we're gonna start very
very soft almost inaudible and gradually
gradually is the key word we're going to
swell to our loudest volume and when we
think we've found it we're going to come
back to being almost inaudible again
gradual is the key word
around there is the peak so I'll head
back word until I fade away to nothing
so find moments in the piece to amplify
the intensity of the moment with a
crescendo and likewise find moments
where the sound is coming to arrest and
let that riddle II settle in with a nice
day crescendo
this is the final and perhaps most
delicate part of any really good tremolo
Roboto is when we stretch time we can
speed up or slow down to highlight the
beauty of a moment and create some Evan
flow in the rhythm let me show you how
this works here's a phrase with no
Roboto and very clean sounds beautiful
because the music is beautiful I even
did a little bit of a crescendo there so
I had some dynamics but if I was to
stretch the time at the most intense
moment the peak of the phrase then we
can create something a little bit more
interesting
[Music]
so I stretched the time to make that
beautiful moment the highest note even
more beautiful by just allowing it a
little bit more time now this is a
highly subjective part of musical
interpretation some might think I'm
using way too much bravado and some
might think I'm using too little but
that's okay because this is sort of the
chocolate and vanilla stage of music
making you get to decide how much spice
you want in your food and how much
Roboto you like in your music so I'd
encourage you to find moments in the
piece which by stretching the time a
little bit can intensify the beauty of
the moment okay so there we have it we
learned how to train our fingers using
specific exercises from part one and a
little bit from today as well if you
practice these regularly you will give
yourself the technical foundation for a
beautiful elegant and even tremolo now
once you've achieved that technical
stability you need to then actually
transcend those technical aspects of
playing and enter the wonderful realm of
musicality and that means using
expressive tools like voice balancing
dynamics and Roboto how you mix those
musical ingredients together is up to
you and your own aesthetic preferences
and in fact one of the reasons we love
to listen to dozens of different
guitarists play the same piece is
because each of us are capable of
creating our own new lovable
interpretation of a piece so it's time
for you to start making your own
thanks so much for watching I really
hope you found this to be useful if you
haven't already please do subscribe and
if you want to help me make more videos
like this you can check out my my
patreon lastly at the time of this video
we are all under quarantine
and are being asked in certain places to
mandatorily wear masks so if you would
like a music themed mask my lovely wife
who goes by the artistic name of we're
iam is a wonderful designer and
illustrator and has come up with some
great music themed masks that you can
check out in the description below see
you next time
you